[Music]
let's go to tiffany in huntsville hey
what's up tiffany
hey john how's it going we are partying
how about you
busy day taking a little moment off from
work good for you good for you if you
want to let's take a long moment we can
just make this call 50 minutes you can
curl up under the desk we can just chit
chat sound good
okay sounds good excellent so what's up
so
my husband and i got married in january
and
here recently my mother-in-law has
decided that she is moving back to
oregon and she has a 37 year old
son who she is
not necessarily
you know kicking us you know kicking him
our way but um
placing us in charge of his care
um
that is diagnosed
that we have paperwork for or nothing
that we have um
any medical
understanding of honestly and that is
where we've
fell in this really awkward position of
do we treat him like an adult or do we
treat him like
he has some sort of special needs
they
are under the
impression that he has high functioning
autism he has a job
as a security person for a bank
but
he is not
functioning
as far as his finances he is
very unstable he does very frivolous
things he can barely
pay for his food he lives with us we
actually bought a huge house so that we
could enable him because i do have two
kids as well so
there's there's a lot to it but we don't
know how to move forward without
hindering
the rest of our marriage or without um
like we want we want to help them but we
don't we also don't want to
um further enable him like he has been
for the last 37 years if you know if if
he is just an enabled individual who has
an excuse essentially yeah
so here here's
how long have you been married
nine ten oh eleven months
your marriage is in trouble isn't it
you're tired you're tired already
no we're definitely not tired we are not
not we what about you
i'm not i'm
i have a very toxic family history so
i'm
this is nothing this is easy 37 year old
dude move in we're good okay
well we
we have a we bought a whole house and we
have a whole house full of people um
we we enable veterans to live with us
and
that's a whole different situation but
um
but with him it is a very much a
we don't know
and we don't have the tools to know if
there's a way of going about
do we get him medically diagnosed
and how does that look like or do we
enable him to be an
adult and then look at the possibility
of him continuing on these really
negative
patterns with his finances and then us
going through and having to deal with
the repercussions of his brother not
financially taking care of himself
and being young in our marriage you know
that that would be a lot for us to
handle that's right
so
whether he has special needs or not
you and your husband have to decide we
are not going to participate
in him living a less than life
and his parents his mom's dad whoever
has
facilitated in him either not getting
the care that he needs to be successful
the accommodations the mental health
care the physical care the physical
therapy the training that he needs
or
which i think is borderline abusive
or
they have just allowed a child
to morph and
slovenly grow into a 37 year old
dependent
right either way you'll have to decide
we're out of that game
so that's that's where it becomes really
difficult on us because his mom is so
hey here's the deal it's not difficult
it's not difficult got it it's hard but
it's not difficult
right okay
mom's out of the picture now she doesn't
get a vote she doesn't get a choice
she's moving
right so her
her influence here is over completely
done
and if she's giving money i'd give her
money back
it's not worth it
you moved
you dropped your 37 year old challenge
on us
fine you're done
we are people who practice hospitality
as a way of life that's who you you and
your husband are you serve veterans you
serve those in your community you got
your own kids great
mom's out
and she can kick and scream and he need
your husband needs to to
suck it up and have a hard conversation
with mom my guess is he doesn't have
that conversation
we've had we recently over the weekend
had a conversation with her that
it's either
one path or the other he's either
disabled and we're going to take
guardianship over him and that's going
to be the end because he's reached a
point that he's morbidly obese like in
he's using his depression to
enable him further in doing death
threats towards his mom and she had a
child commit suicide 10 years ago so
she's already in a very difficult spot
which makes it harder for us to
to be the the hard love in the family
but
listen somebody has to stop the madness
it sounds like it was a trauma
trauma-filled home is that fair
yes
your husband grew up in in hell really
right
yes yeah and
there's probably all kinds of physical
and psychological things going on with
brother
yeah
what y'all can do is you can't save him
he's gotta have to make some choices at
some point what you can do is put him in
a position to be successful and that
starts exactly the conversation you had
and you all had the initial one and now
you're gonna have a putting your foot
down one
either we are gonna become guardians of
somebody with special with an adult with
special needs we're gonna get all the
resources that we need along those lines
we're gonna get him the the health care
that he needs that you mom have not
gotten him for 37 freaking years
for whatever reason i don't blame her i
don't know what her world was like who
knows
what we're dealing with is today
and
he's going to have to be a part of some
solutions what he has to understand is
sitting at home
and just continuing to
slowly take his own life
is not an option
and that might mean that he packs up and
leaves y'all
and you'll have to be prepared for that
but he's a 37 year old man
we would we would be
we would be okay with that
oh thank god that'd be great yeah yeah
yeah our fear i mean our just our fear
with that is that you know he has had
his own house for or his own apartment
for a stint and she just came over and
did his laundry and she made sure his
bills were paid and
if he were to leave the house at this
point then we would be concerned that he
wouldn't make those things happen
because he has a massive internet
addiction
as well that of course
he spent over 30 000 in the last year
just on
things that he shouldn't be and
and
we're at a loss
here's the thing he is
in the ocean
waving his arm for help
and
the people who love him just keep
putting their foot on his head
right
and that just gets to stop with y'all
okay you have to know
taking a 37 year old who has been babied
in this way
or neglected in this way either one of
those two things
is going to be
incredibly hard to change
agreed
real real hard
and you throw in major depression you
throw in internet addiction you throw in
loneliness you throw in mom's enabling
nonsense you throw in obesity you're
talking
the the
comorbid effects here are powerful
exponential they're hard
and it's a long haul
real long hauls i'm just painting a
realistic picture this is not gonna be
like a real good hard weekend
conversation
you're talking about some major shifts
can he do it you're telling you right
now you can
absolutely
do anything he wants to
right but what i want you and your
husband to do is to
get away together
go have a long meal and i say this all
the time but go get a long meal and you
become resolute together
absolutely you all get lockstep this is
what our triggers will be when he's out
you're moving out of our house i don't
care where you're going
or you're going to go to get this
psychiatric workup you're going to go
get an aba work up you're going to go do
whatever we like get a physical workup
or you're gone
you're out of our home because we're not
going to participate in your death
absolutely that that totally makes sense
is that cool and then you and your
husband are on the same page there's no
mix signals there's no well i thought we
were doing this nope we have outlined
this sucker
absolutely we're this the same way with
most things in life so that that totally
i love it
i
yeah just the the
the gross abuse that's been done to this
man
it just sucks
we just don't want to continue on the
same road for the next 40 years of our
life absolutely yeah of course and hey
how old are your kids
uh there's six and eight they're gonna
watch every second of this
absolutely every second and by the way
you grew up in a hard home too
yes absolutely you and your husband got
your own trauma work do you all got to
deal with is that fair
oh yes
will you commit to that
well i have i mean we're both veterans
so we're both
more both in therapy so okay we're good
but you're committed to it
absolutely so good
so good can i just back out 30 000 feet
and just look at you in the eyes even
though we're on the internets here i'm
talking on the phone i just tell you i'm
grateful for you
well thank you our community needs more
people like you in it
thank you i appreciate that and finding
that balance between hospitality and
enabling is hard that's a hard line to
walk
when do you give somebody a meal and
when you give somebody a kick in the
booty and say go get them right that's
hard
and you all navigate that every day by
inviting people into your home fair
absolutely yeah well i'm i'm so grateful
most people sit there spend their whole
life on the sidelines and you have
chosen to get in the messy middle of
that but that does not work
if the two captains aren't well
right absolutely got it
yes you're gonna love this knuckleheaded
husband of yours till the wheels fall
off
yes you're gonna dedicate y'all's lives
to each other
absolutely and you're gonna not lose
intimacy because your house is loud and
crazy
i know
[Laughter]
yes i love it
i love uh no uh no
no and you're gonna love those two
little ones
absolutely and you're not gonna let that
37 year old just
die
no we're not good
the world needs more people like tiffany
thank you so much for being the person
that you are i'm grateful grateful
grateful for you
now you got a mission you got a new
mission you had one in the service and
now you got a new one
and it is rad good for you
strength
day after day sane page clarity
working through it so grateful for you
tiffany hey walk with oh i'll walk with
you let's just say you walk with me i'll
walk with you call me back after you'll
have these hard conversations i'd love
to know how the doctor appointment works
out if he chooses to go i'd love to know
how mom comes
hollering back
because it's going to happen i want to
know how all that goes because we're
going to walk alongside you as you make
some major changes in your lives
and as you get this brother of yours and
your husbands on his two own two feet
again
and change every square inch of his life
2022 is gonna be big for tiffany and
family